starting off this hour is Leslie in
Chattanooga hi Leslie welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show thank you for taking my
call
sure what's up I'm a little back story
and my spouse has some addiction issues
and after getting him into rehab
facility where he is now I am trying to
clean up a financial mess that was made
and he had taken out several I guess
online payday loans and some of them
would to be charging $60.00 a month
tomorrow and there are some that are
charging 350 dollars I'm not in just in
case
and I'm not sure how to go about
starting to pay these off or the
legality of some of these that are
charging you know ridiculous interest
rates
well I'm afraid they're probably in a
state where it is legal to do that
that's my guess anyway and what is your
household income um it's about 16 okay
and how much in loans are these payday
loans are out um let's see about I'm
sorry about $3,000 okay
and what other debts do you guys have
and student loans
how much um oh gosh probably about
50,000 mm-hmm is that on hardship
deferral or you been paying that you
know they're on hardship deferral okay
and how much do you pay on your cars and
we don't our cars are paid for that's
good how much is your house payment half
an it's about $1,100 a month
okay what other dad's do you have um we
have one credit card what's wrong
oh I think the mountain doubtful a
thousand dollars and that's it that's
good news all right do you have another
credit card that's open yeah okay well
there's two ways to deal with the payday
loans obviously if you've got some that
are 350 versus 60 you got to treat the
whole thing like it's on fire you gotta
get them out your life as soon as
possible because they're going to get
worse very fast any of them are
if you've got some 350 instead of 60 I
would go after those and get them out of
the way the other possibility is arm you
know that if you can't pay them at all
that they just go bad and then you
settle with them for close to the
original amount plus some fees but not
you know the things start out at 350
dollar bill and then they add 350 a
month to it which some of them do I mean
it's just it's obscene and then you go
back and settle you know for the
original 350 plus some fees but
certainly not their full boat and you
might call them and just negotiate with
them and set that in place now and say
all right
I can pay you by this date but but we
need to settle the amount we need to set
the amount okay and just lock it in so
it's not just continuing to crank and
then just lay that out and say okay I'm
gonna do two thousand dollars this month
two thousand dollars next month and
these things are going to be out of our
lives and that means beans and rice rice
and beans but hey the family's in a
crisis and so we're going to crank it
down and clean this mess up
okay what is the nature of his addiction
what was he addicted to um gambling okay
and he was using payday lending to do it
yes and his income is to keep his head
above water and his income yes yeah what
what was he making before going into
rehab um it was our intense it was a
time of 60 okay so he was able to take
some time off from work and get paid
yeah so he's on vacation or so and such
and such okay good well that's a good
employer somebody's taking care of him
one way or another there that's that's
pretty impressive very grateful for that
yeah amen this the first time it's
gotten this bad yes okay it's kind of
one of those looking back you know
money's always been a source of
contention and it's just you know
looking back now I could see it coming
but which is not to see things sometimes
no now I'm trying to clean it up yeah
okay well how long y'all been married 20
years
it well it sounds like things are going
the right direction in a really bad
situation that is turning around and
he's admitted what's going on you're
real clear about what's going on you're
taking the steps to turn this thing
around because I'll tell you that
gambling is the second fastest growing
addiction in North America of all the P
all the addicts that with money problems
and they all have money problems they
come into our office for coaching
gambling is the second fastest growing
it's just it's it's all over the place
is bad and penny lenders are the that
just scratches the surface of how bad
this stuff gets so if you need some more
help with this Leslie while you're
fighting this by yourself you just let
us know and we'll help you okay give me
a yell back if you need something
you